[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zu sein heute gibt
es einen richtig leckeren fleck wenn ihr
alle kennt zwar mache ich popcorn bis
und verpasst ich werde euch zuerst im
ersten schritt zeigen wie man spart
hersteller praktisch ohne geschmack ganz
neutral einem topf von einmal mit hilfe
einer küchenmaschine und dann zeige ich
euch eine richtig leckere herzhafte
variante und bisschen mediterran
orientalisch angehaucht und dann noch
eine schöne bitte variante nämlich
regenbogen popcorn das kann man dann
entweder so machen war exportiert oder
auch richtig schön bunt gemischt und ich
würde sagen wir starten jetzt gleich im
cockpit nur mainz und ein bisschen öl um
popcorn herbst brauchen wir im prinzip
nur frei zu haben und zwar bei und ich
hab jetzt ein rapsöl ihr könnt auch ein
sonnenblumenöl nehmen oder zum beispiel
auch ein kokosöl was mann und frau hoch
erhitzen kann danke vom irak bekannt ist
es entweder einen verkehrswert oder ich
mach das auch einmal in der comedia
trainiert führt 5 180 grad und die
temperatur braucht man auch um ein
programm vorstellen
erstmals zeigen sich die zubereitung im
tausch dafür nehmen wir am besten einen
großen topf und hier gibt es das unrein
und erhebt dann bist du nur aufpassen
dass wir uns nicht zu sehr damit das öl
nicht verbrannt gezeigt auf mittel hoher
hitze genügt vollkommen und das altöl
heiß ist gebe ich dann den meisten und
verschließe für ford entwickelt was ganz
wichtig ist dass ihr währenddessen immer
mal wieder den kopf schütteln damit sich
der mainz mit dem öl gut verbinden kann
und eben alles auch schon verteilt
werden ich mache so dass ich die hitze
dann wegnehme und dem herd ausschalten
damit das popcorn nicht verbrennen
und da muss man jetzt auf jeden fall
immer dabei stehen und auch den kopf
immer mal wieder schütteln damit die
popkomm durch mit und damit nichts
anbrennt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so basieren fast auf hören könnt ihr den
topf vom herd herunternehmen den deckel
am besten noch kurz geschlossen lassen
und dann können wir das sofort aufnehmen
jetzt zeige ich euch die zubereitung in
die kinos kommen
die hat die hitze funktion bitte beachte
ich grad und hat bereits eine popcorn
funktion und darin werde ich das jetzt
machen dann kann ich nämlich auch neben
herrn bitte etwas andere frau bereiten
wohl hat ein gleichen sofa leckeres
popcorn
ich zeige euch das mal hier kann man
diesen programmen wählen sie geht hier
auf die programme am tippen dann
vertraglich auf sylt und dann einfach
weiter jetzt von chf 12 sonstige konnten
auch gleich den kopf und ich kann auch
wählen erzählt ihr element entfernen
heißt brühl element entfernen da braucht
man nämlich keins dafür dann die
eingabetaste drücken flughafen zu geben
ist an der stelle jetzt das öl dann
wieder die eingabetaste drücken mit den
geschwindigkeitsregler betätigen
jetzt wird zuerst einmal die öl erhitzt
und ich muss einfach abwarten
wahlergebnis steht dann hier flughafen
verfügungen eingabetaste drücken
dabei ist an dieser stelle kommt der
meister zu vekselberg die maschine das
öl und in mainz einfach wieder auf 108
einfach die zeit vom 10 minuten ab
runter und ich kann jetzt in der
zwischenzeit auf
[Musik]
ist auf beiden seiten fertig natürlich
noch neutral
das heißt im prinzip nur optisch macht
aber nichts da es nicht oder sie gucken
wir auch griff ein und hier im topf muss
man einfach auch neue vierte weg stellen
ansonsten kann es passieren dass es am
topfboden einfach ein brennendes öl im
top wenn da einfach hilfe braucht kann
überhitzen und dann verbrennt euch das
verfahren trägt heißt opfer
und jetzt verwenden wir viel popcorn und
ich zeige euch wie man zuerst die
herzhafte also die salzige varianten
vorbereitet
los geht's mit dem salzigen popcorn
ihr könnt es jetzt schon so machen wir
das gerne möchte ich habe mir eine
gewürzmischung zusammengestellt und zwar
habe ich jetzt paprikapulver currypulver
kümmel salz pfeffer und chili und davon
jeweils etwa einem teelöffel wobei bei
zeitz und vollkommen haben sie etwa
einen halben teelöffel genommen die
mischung kommt jetzt hier rein und dann
wird alles gut
[Musik]
und wenn es fertig ist sieht so aus und
hat eine richtig schöne natürliche farbe
[Musik]
jetzt zeigen wir euch wie man
bundesparlament popcorn hersfeld und
wahrnehmen
das passt und werden den zucker mit
lebensmittelfarbe passten ein werbung
sitzt er gelb orange blau grün lila und
pink in flieden den flughafenbus
trocknen lassen muss man aber nicht man
kann ihn auch gleich weiter verlängern
hier zeige ich euch zubereitung im
normalen topf nehmen einfach ein
bisschen wasser in den abgekühlten topf
ryanair vorfeld mit wasser und fett und
da gibt's an ihrer ihr verein da gibt
hier einfach zucker nach geschmack und
für den leckeren geschmack kommt noch
etwas lang
[Musik]
jetzt lassen wir den zucker mit dem
wasser einfach aufkochen und es
verhindert einfach auf das karamell zu
schnell verbrennt und deswegen mache ich
immer gerne die variante mit wasser
[Musik]
jetzt müssen nur aufpassen dass es euch
nicht verbrennen dabei bleiben und so
bled immer kleiner werden habe ich
parallel und fand dann die temperatur
auf automessen floristin ganz klein ist
wahrlich ein herz aus sie muss und jetzt
kommt noch eine handvoll und jetzt gut
durchrühren
[Applaus]
jetzt kommt es per e-mail popcorn raus
und muss sich abkühlen lassen im
kanzleramt so ein bisschen voneinander
trennen
[Musik]
jetzt auf die zubereitung in der gummi
programm aufgenommen und gebe ich hier
auf zucker wasser und von den extrakt
rein und wer das jetzt erhielten auf 180
grad und sobald das karamell bereit ist
vom top-rang mit dazu und wird guckt
euch gerührt
[Musik]
wenn
fertig ist man doch fragen und ich
find's richtig schön hier habe ich das
unter druck kommen schön gemischt und
falls diese gruppen haben möchtet oder
farbe macht ihr einfach die schritte
genau so nur fügt eben keine farbe sind
so also ganz normalem futter wasser und
wann die vanille entwicklung alle kampf
und es gibt diese partner foxconn besser
für meine schwägerin geliefert kann über
alles aber nicht so ich würde mich
gleich er auf das tiefe stürzten
und falls ihre konzept nach machen wollt
dann geht auch wenn ich mit blog.de
da steht noch mal auf die genauen
schritte und ich wünsche euch ganz viel
spaß dabei und gab es zunächst normal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er floh
[Musik]